vous parlez vous parlez du pacte de
stabilité emmanuel maurel mario draghi
emmanuel macron ces deux anciens
banquiers qui vont faire sauter les
verrous budgétaire de l'europe notamment
par un assouplissement durable des pas
des règles du pacte de stabilité
déjà j'entends qu'on compare monsieur
draghi à monsieur macron si je file la
métaphore oui certes c'est monsieur
draghi est monsieur macron mais ça
serait monsieur macron qui gouvernerait
avec madame le pen parce que c'est ça la
situation du gouvernement italien
aujourd'hui je il ya eu autre chose qui
me qui me choque dans ce qu il vient d
dit moi je crois pas du tout que
monsieur draghi est sauvé l'europe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au moment de
la crise il ya eu un accord entre
monsieur sarkozy et madame merkel qui
était d'accord pour changer de politique
monétaire à ce moment là monsieur
trichet qui résistaient a été remplacé
monsieur parle monsieur draghi mais je
drague il a fait ce qu'on lui demandait
c'est à dire transport transformer la
banque centrale en prêteur en dernier
ressort si elle reste qu'avec macron qui
vont faire qui est qui va faire sauter
les verrous budgétaire de l'union
européenne
j'en suis pas si sûr parce que j'ai bien
écouté le discours de monsieur draghi à
la fois il dit oui je vais mettre en
oeuvre le plan de relance de 200
milliards qui est donnée pour l'italie
pour de l'investissement public mais en
même temps il donne sans arrêter cage au
plus dur de la commission européenne et
notamment les allemands il dit on va
continuer dans les réformes
structurelles et il ajoute on va réduire
le périmètre de l'état lors comment on
fait pour mener grande politique
d'investissement public très nécessaire
pour l'italie en même temps en réduisant
le périmètre de l'état c'est à dire des
acteurs de l'action publique d'un mois
j'attends de voir
c'est pour ça que je suis inquiet non
non non mais sur les pavés stabilité en
inde - un occasion historique et je
crois qu'elle est travail commun que je
souhaite
emmanuel macron emma de drague avec
d'autres alliés vont faire au niveau
européen pour réformer les packs de
stabilité sur la ligne qui a été déjà un
ps qui sait par parle aux intellos ni
les commissaires européens responsables
à succès une occasion qu'on peut pas
rater et je crois que il faut absolument
on peut rendre les pavés sabilité
finalement plus intelligent en
promouvant les heures 20 heures
investissements publics notamment pour
réduire les inégalités sociales la
transforme pour la transformation
numérique
[Musique]